I uh I mentioned this a couple times I
visited Gettysburg read a whole bunch of
plaques and actually I mean for people
who don't know the area where we are
with Harper's Ferry with Antietam we
ride our bikes to Antietam battlefield
for like coffee it's really crazy to
like you know growing up in Chicago not
seeing this stuff and everywhere you go
there's like these these these
historical plaques they have explaining
what happened there and there's cannons
everywhere and then I watch a
documentary and I thought to myself uh
if the Republicans
abortion is very much the same same on
the same moral level as slavery it's not
necessarily you know I know that you can
be there could be arguments on one being
worse than the other I'm not saying that
I'm saying as an issue of moral conflict
I I think that
it is very likely the Republicans do ban
abortion it does cause a dramatic
escalation and I do think that abortion
if we are to follow the historical track
in human rights expansion abortion will
be outright banned it will be abolished
completely and then we will look back on
whatever Civil War happens because of it
assuming it does the same way we look at
slavery that is not an opinion
personally about pro-choice or pro-life
it's an opinion about historical track
track records but do you really think
that like women are the people that care
about the abortions do you think that
there would be a civil war over abortion
I don't like well
this is exactly the point people don't
know enough about the Civil War neither
do I when I actually went went to
Gettysburg for the first time and in
fact living out here talked to a lot of
people you know met people out here have
told me stories went up to Gettysburg
and then actually read everything and
talked to a few people then I watched
this documentary I was like wow
what percentage of people in the United
States own slaves at the time of the
Civil War I think it was five percent
so if you came out and said come on
slave owners you think there's gonna be
a fight a civil war over slavery when
only when the Confederacy is is four
million uh white population and only 25
percent own slaves that's only five
percent of the entire country that was
also tied up in males male ego in that
like hey this is like this is our our
state or this is what we believe in
whatever when it comes to abortion it's
a female that's why when robots people
are in the chat disagreeing so when men
care
we're divided by States right now some
states are Banning some states are not
sure what I'm saying didn't you notice
that when Roe v Wade was overturned we
had no riots none where were the riots
they just automatically disappeared
right it's supposed to be one of the
hottest issues there and we had zero
riots with people prepared for them
people did everything nope but when
George Floyd gets killed or whatever it
has to men are not going to go out and
fight so that you can so that when I'm
telling you you got it you got to read
more about the Civil War in that case
because I see what you're saying the
idea that the average Southerner went
out and grabbed a gun saying slavery the
government of the Confederacy was trying
to enshrine slavery for sure but the
average Southerner that was fighting was
not a slave owner but it wasn't a
woman's issue they don't care men are
not going to get up and fight over a
woman's issue because abortion is
primarily about women being sexually
available for men but also that's why a
lot of people are wrong but this is a
moral issue of Human Rights no I agree
that like but men are not going to be
like driven to the streets and and like
they weren't they were not riding in the
streets when Roe v Wade was overturned I
mean I didn't even see women riding not
like it's in their nature anyway but
they couldn't get much done if they try
there's not gonna I just don't like I
saw them dressing up like a handmaid's
tale yeah that's what they do when they
go and challenge I saw them doing that
right taking attention nothing there was
no destruction Sheamus made this point
several times he said that in U.S
history there has never been a conflict
seeking to guarantee human rights that
has has that has gone towards stripping
them away in the long run right
basically as as we've moved forward as a
nation and progressed we've continually
expanded human rights not rescinded them
the argument that it's women's rights to
choose is it's the same as arguing in my
opinion that a slave owner has a right
over someone else's body granted there's
a difference between an unborn fetus and
a you know human beings who are being on
I think slavery is very very obviously
wrong and I think we came on the right
side of that one historically but the
argument that someone has a right to
choose to terminate someone else's life
is is it's a very very bad thing now for
me I fall in the more libertarian Camp
of I also don't like the idea of the
government coming in and determining
someone has to give their body to
somebody else which makes it an
impossible ethical standard that I'm not
going to pretend to have the answers to
because I just I don't know it's a body
inside a body it's two separate bodies
it's two bodies right and so you're
trying to argue about civil rights but
the way uh Sheamus put it many other
pro-lifers is that the temporary uh uh
displacement of the woman's uh you know
the woman's life for the permanent life
of the baby is the is the is is the
proper uh outcome meaning killing the
life of the baby
to to help the woman to save the woman
nine to ten months of suffering is is is
inequivocal inequivocal or you know what
I'm trying to say it doesn't balance out
right they're arguing that it's
unfortunate the woman has to suffer but
the baby gets to live a full life of 70
to 80 years whereas you can kill a baby
with no life just so the woman doesn't
have to go through 10 months or or so
nine months of I say 10 because there's
before and there's afterwards there's
postpartum and there's things like that
so there's going to be this this period
from and but but anyway look in my
political opinion is not uh and it's
funny that I can say this because like
imagine being in the time of slavery and
being like trying to be a Centrist where
you're like well you know I personally
think it's wrong but I'm not gonna
abolish it I understand the position I'm
in especially historically but just
reading about the Civil War reading
about how no one cared about it like
this is the crazy thing the
abolitionists were extremists they were
a small tiny faction no one cared about
and it was like five percent of the
country that actually had slaves and so
it was rich white Southern uh southern
slave owners that made up it was about
25 percent of the Southern population
which ultimately because it's a small
population
and uh most people didn't care I was I
was reading I was I was watching a video
talking about the politics the papers
the propaganda and it was like
people in the north didn't care for war
here's a really great example the the
Emancipation Proclamation didn't
actually abolish slavery in like three
states only the states that were in
Rebellion against the the union and so
Lincoln was actually promising like
Maryland and I think Missouri the right
to keep slaves because they weren't
rebelling against the union it's it's
didn't Lincoln also want the
repatriation of former slaves what do
you mean like he wanted African slaves
to be repatriated to their home Liberia
yeah not just Liberia but like no they
there was a thing that they would send
groups of them back over to Africa and
repatriots anyway are you like are you
suggesting though that um a civil war
kicked off by a federal decision on
abortion would
Maybe
be more destructive to the country
because abortion affects more people
than slavery ever did no no no no what
I'm saying is people are saying right
now abortion can't like there's not
gonna be a civil war of abortion like
nobody cares that much it's like okay go
read the history of the Civil War and
see how many people cared about that
issue nobody cared about that yeah there
there were a lot of people Hans
Christian Hague we talked a bit about
him because he was a foreigner who
fought and died for the union
abolitionists were real John Brown was
was real depending on your perspective
on History he was either a hero or he
was a terrorist I mean these are crazy
stories you think about I want you to
Imagine This a guy goes to uh gets a
bunch of his kids and his friends and
family and gets guns and goes to an
abortion clinic walks right after the
doctor and blows his head off that's
John Brown was John Brown a hero because
he was doing that to slave owners he
walked there's there's a story about how
he went to uh he went he wasn't I think
it was in Kansas he didn't care to ask
any questions he didn't care to take
prisoners he just went up and started
killing these people and and he's
considered a hero because slavery was so
wrong what I'm saying is at the time
people didn't in the north didn't care
because the North like it was a
political issue for sure
but people in North were like hey look
first of all segregation lasted until
the 50s so you need to understand that
even the north people were very racist
and were for segregation and didn't you
know didn't care for for doing uh more
lynchings persisted until the 1900s this
idea that the north were like great
Heroes of equality is just not true my
point is not to not look I'd watch the
document in Civil War so here I'm
talking about it no I'm thinking that
what the Republic we we we're looking at
States separate staunchly on abortion
Colorado No Limits Texas bans we're
seeing these states light up in this way
and I'm just like man if the Republicans
move in that direction it's not
I think people underestimate how how
politics works I would say it would it
could be just like slavery was some like
tip of the iceberg or tilt the scales
type of issue it's not going to be like
a driving factor that sets it off there
may be some power dynamics there may be
some other stuff going off and that's
exactly right so there's a lot of stuff
that I'm I've so I've been reading about
the Civil War quite a bit then going to
Gettysburg got me to read a lot a bit
more and watch this documentary
and the Confederacy was definitely
trying to enshrine slavery the the vice
president overtly expressed white
supremacy as the as the core as one of
the cores of the Confederacy like
literally expressing his genetic
superiority and a bunch of other stupid
nonsense but for the average person in
the South they weren't fighting a war
because they had sex they didn't so what
what what they what a lot of people were
telling me is the South knowing that
they needed to boost morale by creating
other issues by by highlighting other uh
eccentricities of the federal government
uh presenting conspiracies and things
like that Robert E Lee didn't even own
slaves and didn't believe in slavery
right so so here's what ends up
happening with the battle at Fort Sumter
it's the fighting that breaks out was
not because the north was like we must
march on the south to end slavery it was
two years after the start Abraham
Lincoln signs the Emancipation
Proclamation which explicitly said only
in rebelling States so even then they
weren't trying to end it so it was the
star it was the core like principle
reason for the conflict and the paranoia
between the South and the north but the
fighting itself was just like tribal
hatred and that was under production
tomb right like there the the whole
reason that the north won was because
they held all the means of production
which is what always scares me
manufacturing yeah manufacturing right
and it's held by the right right now
yeah I thought China is holding them
that is always my thing and I was like
did we not learn anything from the Civil
War who wins the war the people with the
means of production and that goes for
antibiotics that goes for steel
production neon all the things let me
let me tell you some more stuff that
that'll freak you out a little bit a lot
of people say you know Bill Maher he
says if there's another civil war all
right there can't be another civil war
because the Mason-Dixon Line would go
through Nana's Kitchen it's like okay
Bill we get it you're snide but anyway
anyway I think it was
um Robert E Lee or it may have I think
it was a lead and he uh these were these
were Union Generals and the question of
secession was coming up and they said
who do you side with what am I supposed
to do and I think it was Lee who said he
could not Envision raising his arms
against his home state so ultimately he
said I have to go to the South against
Virginia right yeah against Virginia
correct so I want you to imagine
California
and what would happen with the National
Guard if California says outright
any any child can get a sex change any
woman can get an abortion no matter what
and then the National Guard says are we
going to uphold this it's clearly in
violation of federal law I mean
president DeSantis has already banned
this federally and now we're forced to
uphold it it's a question for each and
every one of these National Guardsmen
you live in California your friends are
in California your mom's in California
dad's there your shopkeeper you know the
local Town councilman do you raise your
arms against them we don't have you it's
not against that we don't have the same
loyalty to where we come from anymore at
all that's all been that's all it's not
about the state it's about your friends
and family in that state and whether
you're going to be the one rounding them
up and locking them in camps as
dissenters or going to be the one
defending them
yeah I just when the if the if the Union
soldiers were to march on Virginia and
go and occupy those towns would you be
the one point in the gun at at your
friends and family or would you be the
one defending them
I mean how much people have like family
that like there that much I I just don't
think that your families are spread out
as much as you think they are like it's
not it's not going to be like you know
I've got my mom in Pennsylvania and my
brother and I'm in my mom in New Jersey
my brother in Pennsylvania and like I
have to pick it's gonna be like hey you
guys come with me we're going to be on
the right side of History we all have
our political values that are exactly
the same and we're on a team but no
one's no one's thinking that
you being ordered to March into your old
neighborhood and tell everyone to stay
in their houses while you're holding a
rifle and them being like get out of
here we've said no to you I could do
that if it was ideologically aligned so
we had John podesta doing that uh that
war game in 20 2020 where uh I think it
was podesta you had the Democrats and
neocon Republicans basically playing
Dungeons and Dragons for politics and
The Advocate the Democrats advocated in
their scenario for the west coast to
secede from the union if Donald Trump
were to win a second term as president
the federal government then says we are
giving explicit orders to the National
Guard to go out and stop these people
from doing it and then you have to ask
yourself are you going to protect your
family or protect the federal government
that's what Robert E Lee was basically
saying it's not a question of being like
the word Virginia means so much to me
and the word United States does too but
I was born in Virginia so I choose that
word no it's like yo I'm not going to
point a gun at my neighbor bill
yeah get out of here you're not marching
on my my hometown it's not going to
happen you know what's interesting about
this whole thing it's funny because I
feel like if California wants to succeed
we'd allow that but like I always feel
like the left would never let us go like
they would never let the right seat like
that we would say all right you want to
go you want to have California go have
California and they would be like no you
can't go if we if Texas wanted to say
well I'll give you I'll give you the
shout out Luke on this one because you
keep talking about peaceful divorce
right and that's exactly what the South
was saying an amicable split and the
north said we won't let you lead right
like we won't let you leave and I think
that that's akin to the left now and the
right like if the right all said okay
we're tired of your weird policies you
have you know this half in Canada and
we'll have the bottom half they would be
like no you're never leaving and then
once they see that it's great down here
they would come over and invade us
anyway what was that YouTube channel I
mentioned earlier what what if all
history what if all history he basically
said in his video that the right is
almost is basically guaranteed to win in
all aspects military training resources
food production hands down no questions
asked capability in general the the
entirety of Rural America is connected
and the the leftist America is islands
is it's it's where they call the
Democrat archipelago uh something like
that I mean he made the point that it's
you know the the coastal Elite basically
a similar point to that but it's true
all the production be it manufacturing
be it food growth Etc occurs in the
center of the country and then
everything else goes out to the coasts
we still have manufacturing we have a
little bit marginally I don't know yeah
it's it's not that significant a lot of
the stuff is just imported because of
globalization policies instituted by
David Rockefeller uh but but at the end
of the day you know it it's a hard thing
to to really talk about because how do
you how do you fix this larger divide
that's getting farther and farther from
each other how do you fix people that
are becoming more violent against each
other for their political ideas how can
you even have a peaceful divorce how can
you have a divorce maybe that even has a
mutual peace pact or a mutual defense
impact is that possible but you know
it's it's a hard question to kind of
knowledge it's never been solved I don't
think it can so you know I'm I'm in
Gettysburg and you know what all these
people up there telling me they give
tours and stuff they said well you know
the Civil War was Unfinished Business
from The Revolution from from the war
from independence from the from the
colonial days and I'm like uh-huh and so
what you're basically saying is that all
of these major issues that have been
affecting the country they all they all
connect all the way back it just goes on
forever so you get you get Civil War you
get reconstruction I was reading that
there's not even an official date to the
end of the Civil War because some
Confederate soldiers kept fighting even
though there was the the apatamax
surrender then you had the
Reconstruction then you had this this
Council hearing it was like 1876 I think
where they there was contested election
so they just had a committee meeting of
like okay I guess we'll just decide
you'll be president so we don't go to
Civil War again but then you end up with
the clan Nathan Bedford Forrest who was
who I think he was was he a general in
the Civil War or he was a writer's an
officer a general
then you get the clan then you get civil
rights and you get all that conflict and
now we're still dealing with remnants of
all of that and fighting is coming out
granted a lot of it's washed away almost
everyone universally in this country
opposes racism to a great degree there's
small factions that are still in favor
of it the left seems to be the most in
favor so it's getting weird and murky
yeah I think the best thing we could
strive to do is reduce harm
um any way we can this is why I kind of
advocate for a peaceful divorce or even
just trying to work it out where we
don't have a strong federal government
that keeps imposing its ideas onto
everyone and I think the more we allow
Choice the more we try to get rid of a
centralized big federal government that
could be Republican or Democrat pushing
the ideas onto different states I think
the better off we would be and the less
harm and the less conflict we would have
I totally disagree I feel like that's
not like a reality situation I think
that there's Cycles to every government
there's rise and falls and there's war
and that is a nature and part of being
human is is these cycles of of
government and control and power and
that we are at a point where it's going
to come to a head there's going to be a
fight for whatever is right and then
this cycle we'll start over again and
I'm like let's just get there I'm not
saying you're wrong but I think we
should try to avoid getting there I
think we shouldn't be racing there
because when Americans start fighting
Americans that's really going to be
extremely dangerous and harmful to
everyone and I think we should be doing
our best to reduce harm in that uh in
that YouTube video I keep referencing uh
from what is it what of all history
right yeah whatever history he mentions
Strauss how generational Theory and he
actually expands upon it that it's not
just in the United States but in the
English-speaking world every 80 years of
the conflict and he mentions a couple
more before the American war for
independence and then he also mentions I
think three other books that have this
is really fascinating he goes through a
bunch of different theories that I'll
talk about the past and the ebb and flow
of civilization and Chaos yeah great
videos and they all say in the 2020s
we're going to have chaos and then you
have MIT I believe who came out and said
in the 2020s is it what is it like in
the 80s and then 40 years we're going to
see major chaos and strife in the United
States so they're all predicting it
maybe maybe they're all wrong and I
won't need to eat the beans in my
basement I don't know if they're all
wrong but I will say that if you look at
cycles and trends of civilization and
when they fall it's always with the
um loosening of sexuality especially
when it comes to women well
civilizations usually have that
correlation as well as the degradation
of society entertainment a lot of it is
just weird awkward doesn't make a lot of
sense and I think we are in that phase
yeah because fourth turning as some
people referencing there's that thought
I was reading that book what was it um
the
the Age of Enlightenment right uh
entitlement the age of entitlement oh I
keep doing this with the mic okay so the
age of entitlement
um and he says in there like there is
always a battle of that of like your
personal need for flexibility and
sexuality versus your the structural
need for survival and constraints on
your sexuality
um and that's like what the story of
Romeo and Juliet was and that there's
always that conflict and when the one of
the individual wins out and that's when
Society really deteriorates because
you're missing that that construction of
the family and and restraint that you
need in order to live in civil society
and so it's it's really women burning
their bras in their 60s it ruined
everything for us but it's not just in
the 60s though because feminism started
way before that I know but it was a big
movement witchcraft in in the 19th
century really
right I mean like women learning math
I mean ultimately we can blame the
printing press for everything oh yeah
for everything that's gone wrong how do
you uh how do you create a society where
people are uh
free as individuals to live in and
choose as they see fit I don't think you
should have less and less government
have less people dependent on government
people dependent on government stay
dependent on government because it hooks
them in the government dares not to
solve is not there to solve any problems
but it's there to get people who will
need them forever but I'm talking about
culturally you think you're saying you
think women I've made yeah I've
definitely made a further like turn I
guess re I guess within the last like
years years maybe two years or so
further to the right in that there's
another good book that I'll quote on
cerebrumari's book and he he said this
great little like anecdotal thing it's a
and I've kid so I know so you bring two
kids to the sandbox for like 18 months
old one kid brings a toy they're both
sitting in the sandbox the other kid
steals the toy from the kid and the kid
says hey that's mine you can't have that
starts freaking out right so that gives
you a thing that that's not like taught
in society there's an inherent sense of
justice and right and wrong and morality
but a mom comes in or some you know or a
dad or somebody comes and says yo we
don't live like that we live in Civil
Society in this town so while I think
that you need to
um you know embrace the individual and
give them some flexibility and some
freedom to grow there I do think that
there needs to be some agreed upon very
you know moral structure there and I
think that we've gone past that and
everybody has all these like dark images
about like authoritarianism and things
like that because we've seen it get out
of control but there's also been a lot
of benevolent benevolent dictators
there's also been kings that have wound
up you know occurring sainthood because
they were so good to their people and so
I just think that they're we are so
lacking in immorality that there needs
to be some not everybody is capable of
I mean think look around like look at
the supermarket and people aren't
capable of making their own decisions on
what food to buy I think that there just
needs to be some structure in the
society and it needs to be something we
all agree on and we are far past that's
not a right or left thing I mean
Bloomberg said we should tax the poor
because they're too stupid to make their
own decisions he said well when we tax
them we can spend the money better
because they tend to make mistakes
something like that do they mean the
poor do they mean the middle class
he meant I'm not talking about personal
decisions like that much I I mean more
some more enforced morality some you
know like we used to shame people we
used to you know scoff against divorce
we use it and and people have like
totally exploited all that it used to be
for some some basic reason like some
serious reasons that people get divorced
or leave their family or anything like
that or men would go outside the home or
no no fault no fault divorce was the end
of it entirely completely 100 marriage
no longer exists tests with no fault
everybody lifts up Reagan right but
Reagan Reagan was awful gun control I
mean you ran Contra horrible yeah yeah
horrible guy I mean I'm just saying that
like I think that there needs to be some
bounded morality and I think that yeah
you know it that sounds scary to a lot
of people but I think that it's the only
way out of this thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there